- escribe esto - de esto hoy vamos
a hablar más en inglés e italiano,
así es, Emma está en un
desafío de 90 días, entonces, ¿
qué te resulta difícil en inglés?
y es difícil para mí elegir, por lo que
este tipo es muy difícil para mí entender
bien, sí, quiero decir, las preposiciones son
difíciles en muchos idiomas, sí, más baratas
en pobres pobres y para ver bien, está bien,
sabes que puedo mirar las reglas que no
recuerda las reglas,
sí, esto es un problema, así que básicamente
con la pornografía, pero me imagino que si estoy hablando
mucho español
mm-hm en este momento, voy a ir a
Argentina, ¿verdad, qué bueno, sí,
así que estoy hablando mucho  español,
entonces mejoraré, sí, así que digamos que
podría tener un 60 % de razón entre por y
para.
es
correcto, podría mejorar aún más
y luego hay algunos verbos  en
español to take our don't take our
sí, lo hay, pero puedes leer todas
las reglas y no puedes recordar las
reglas, sí, entonces, ¿qué te parece difícil
una imagen con proposiciones si vas a
algún lugar, sí, o de  de sí, tal
vez soy yo, pero yo, sí, está bien, cuento desde
España, sí, ven, presiona reproducir es de, es
muy fácil,
sí, bueno, tal vez me das, a veces me
doy cuenta de que están en un ejército a
veces como en eso, sí,
porque son diferentes
son muy diferentes y no hay un
razonamiento real por eso dices que sabes en
Vancouver en lugar de en Vancouver por
qué sabes que dices en la estación de tren
no dices en la estación de tren sí,
pero cuando estás en la estación de tren
tú  puedo decir que estoy en la estación de tren pero
si nos vamos a encontrar digo que te encontraré
en la estación de tren estoy en el
tren estoy en el tren en el tren
también puedes decir estoy en el  tren pero sobre
todo es estoy en el tren estoy en el taxi o
en el taxi en el taxi nunca  en taxi
esas son frases asi que tienes que guardar
eso en el tren estoy en el tren estoy
en el metro tu puedes en el metro estoy
en el pero estoy en el bus en el bus para
que puedas estar  en sabes que estoy en el auto
y no en el auto en el auto en el auto
sí, no en el auto porque en su
famoso y lo diré simplemente, me refiero a
todos, pero fue más fácil, no,
lo sé, lo sé para  responde es
complicado di lo que estoy seguro de que hay
reglas
sí no me preguntes cuáles son las reglas pero
puedes buscar las reglas no estoy en
contra de buscar reglas puedes buscar
reglas no lo estoy  no sé cuánto
ayuda ayuda un poco ayuda un
poco
vas, ja, ja, está bien, pero luego lo olvidas,
sí, pero es como una
explicación.
mira hacia arriba sabes que hoy puedes googlear
preposiciones en inglés puedes ver
un montón de cosas puedes leer
lo que es más importante creo que es guardar
frases estoy en el auto estoy  en el tren
estoy en el tren también puedes decir estoy en
el tren estoy ahí estoy en un
avión sí no estoy en un avión en
el avión sugerir que estás encima
del avión  está bien, no es tan bueno, ¿es
solo en un en o en como si no hubiera un en
en español, verdad? No, no creo que esté
en en español y solo funciona en todas partes.
en
por si por para mí diría para mí un
loro sabes que no diría pobre de mí
no pero podrías decir pobre de mí fiesta
es eso significa lo mismo sí ves sí
no yo una cosa si saliste así que yo
Probablemente estoy acostumbrado a fiestas para mí, pero
me equivoco, sí, lo mismo con ser y
estar.
te equivocarás, sí,
así que mi enfoque es trabajar en frases
para escuchar y leer mucho y
esperar que  te equivocarás
y con el tiempo, con más exposición, más
uso y esas cosas, incluso si la gente
no te corrige, comenzarás a mejorar,
sí, eso es todo, te pareció
natural, lo sé, en el tren, sí.
Creo que sí, porque no necesitas
memorizar su regla, necesitas hacerlo si cada
vez que vas a hablar porque usamos
preposiciones con tanta frecuencia, sí, es extraño, ya
sabes, y agrega desde arriba abajo, sea
lo que sea, las usamos con tanta frecuencia si
cada vez que tienes que pensar en una
regla una explicación
sí creo que tendrías problemas para
hablar tienes que hablar sí tienes
que hablar tienes algo que quieres
decir tienes que hablar sí porque
creo que cuando tienes razón está bien tú  no puedo
pensar que sabes todo eso bien como cuando
hablas puedes estar bien y cuando
estás escribiendo incluso puedes buscarlo si estoy
escribiendo Hago esto todo el tiempo como en
idiomas donde sabes como en
idiomas eslavos donde  todos los finales cambian
no estoy seguro de un final miro
sí, si estoy escribiendo, sí, puedo
buscarlo incluso si está en español. No estoy seguro de
si es masculino o femenino. No hay
nada. Puedo buscarlo.
para hablar, sí,
pero creo que es por eso que escribir a
veces es muy bueno porque sabes
que es, por ejemplo, es lamagno, cierto,
sí, termina en oh, pero es lamagno mm-hmm, de
alguna manera, a veces es un poco difícil,
sí, cuando escribes, eres  recordé
que es lamagno entonces, cuando vas a
hablar, finalmente desarrollas mejores
hábitos
ahí arriba como un no como la
apodo Lo sé, pero no, escribí mi camino
alrededor del escritorio un UPS o un canal web ou
Lai en lo mismo que je parle inglés
romántico y creo que otra cosa
es ser optimista mm-hmm  así que
cuando estoy aprendiendo ahora mismo estoy
aprendiendo árabe o Fars  yo o lo que sea
sé que voy a mejorar como solo
sé que voy a mejorar sé que voy
a aprender más palabras voy a
entender cada vez mejor realmente no
hablo mucho todavía pero lo haré
finalmente hablo cada vez mejor como
sé que espero con ansias
es como si fuera a casa y sé
que voy a tener una buena cena sé
que tengo que tener una buena cena estoy
deseando que llegue y  lo mismo con los
idiomas si sigues escuchando y
leyendo y prestando atención y guardando
palabras y frases mejorarás
sí y creo que es importante
tener esa actitud mucha gente pasa
como diez años estudiando inglés en la
escuela y todavía comete errores  y
a veces se desaniman, pero
parte de eso se debe a que están tratando
de recordar reglas, sí,
reglas muy difíciles de recordar,
solo tienes que escuchar y
leer tanto que ciertos hábitos los conoces si las
cosas se vuelven más y más naturales
con el tiempo.  si y yo  Es algo que puede
esperar con confianza. Sí,
sabe que mejorará.
el video con nuestro primer video, sí,
y será interesante ver cómo te
sientes al final, sí,
entonces te encanta este televisor, bueno, no tienes más
importante, más importante, está bien
[Música]